my leg was kind of rough I had an awful
battle my fragile psyche the game I
can't repeat the name it's what your
head does of the work and everything
will change
Zippity be a patient hell the tricky
[Music]
it's the kind of swirl it's that kind of
it's that signature at the end kind of
[ __ ] what's good everybody it's tea time
with me time 902 May 20th we're in it
now we are fully in quarantine now now
it's real life
now regular life is weird hope everybody
super well really appreciate being on
with me just a great show yesterday
let's see if we can match it Dustin on
the ones and twos doesn't how are you my
friend excellent excellent
anything interesting I'm trying to see
if the LinkedIn comments or oh yes
linger in big shout-out to LinkedIn I
know LinkedIn update I don't see the
comments in here I don't see them either
looks like a huge fail once again for
the doctor no no no yeah oh there they
are
there we go Tariq the first LinkedIn
comment I've seen big shout out to
Christopher Gonzalez what is up LinkedIn
you are in the that was a periscope
there we go
sauce doesn't have a lot of Lincoln's
may not have logos oh there she is
anne-marie LaBelle good morning good
morning LinkedIn is now in the building
on the public chats excited about that
there we go with Matt Shaw Facebook
Instagram before we get into this please
Oh Instagram big shot at the Instagram
because you know we go ghetto with it
because it doesn't tap what stream yard
this platform use which is remarkable
but what Sana'a think holds it up so big
shout out to everybody on instagram I
love you so now I'm you know now we're
live in LinkedIn twitch Facebook Twitter
and YouTube all comments enabled
Instagram is the only live place were at
where the comments are not enabled
correct yep all right let's get into
show Rudy from LinkedIn look at the
LinkedIn fam let's get the LinkedIn
everyone looked and share this share
this live please let's get the LinkedIn
share volume going let's get into share
mode everybody in general all right
let's get this going
I can't Atias what's good yep how you
doing what's going on Gary good one good
morning to you gentlemen thanks for
being on what's chicken yeah we started
making beats and uh seven am online back
in 2011 kind of just building a fanbase
growing a solid income and over the
years we started to become one of the
top sellers online landing some
replacements I'm eventually would tear a
wack bad bunny juice world and don't
prove that you know we got you know I'd
say it's oddly solid base probably
twenty thirty thousand customers over
the years and wanted to add something
with him what would you recommend the
new artist to do in service of nine
music kinds here is important yeah I
think yeah I think you I can't believe
you guys just brought this up literally
workshopping up a business at Vayner
land last night and I talked about we're
talking about artists and you know as
you to know me Mike Boyd a lot of us
we've spent a lot of time in the space
but we're not looking to start a label
or go into management but we did get
into this conversation of like how
multi-dimensional artists are and need
to be to really take it to the next
level and I think any artist in the
world that can that can do other [ __ ]
needs to right right like like if you're
capable of being funny on tik-tok if
you're a super model looking person if
if you're funny and you can do Instagram
code if you can do a podcast I mean I
mean look at your button like right like
like this podcast absolutely give some
unlimited leverage if he was in the mood
to drop a project it would matter right
look at look at Khaled Khaled and
tighter
Callens made hundreds of millions of
dollars on the back of a five day
execution on snapchat so of course of
course I mean you know and that's
something we've always enamored and and
and put on a pedestal
JLo beyond
people that could do more right you know
people that could do more so yeah I mean
I actually would argue the debate in 20
years will be should any artist just do
music right like it's almost like it's
almost like the reverse you know the
internet just creates obnoxious levels
of opportunity you guys lived it I lived
it
like people don't get it like you look
at Latin trap you look at bad bunny
Balvin you know search all that that
whole movement right like run the tone
like like like you know it doesn't
happen without the internet I mean I
mean the record like like MTV didn't
want to play Michael Jackson you know
like because you know racism subjective
calls I'll give you another classic one
the person that ran CBS or whatever the
network Gilligan's Island on was on his
wife like loved some show that nobody
gave a [ __ ] about they cancelled it when
they unveiled the fall schedule in 1958
or 62 or whatever [ __ ] that was she she
went ham and her [ __ ] husband kicked
out Gilligan's Island and put her
[ __ ] showing that is the reason
there aren't 100 more episodes of
Gilligan's Island crazy as well that
doesn't that doesn't happen that doesn't
happen in the Internet we can all do
everybody watching this morning can can
do and and and should and so if you're
an and now the artists big shout out to
like you know Pharrell you know Pharrell
and you know by making nerd culture or
other you know big shout out to [ __ ]
you know Andre 3000 like you know the
culture now let's you'd be anything you
want to be into [ __ ] some dorky [ __ ]
that was unacceptable in 1994 now you
can do anything which which then means
you could do anything right like like
Tyler the Creator Pharrell you know lil
yachty that [ __ ] doesn't fly in 1996 hip
hop that was narrow row now you know you
can do anything so if you're silly on
tick tock but you but you [ __ ] talk
hard lyrics from the south side of it
Lana on Spotify you can actually get
away with that [ __ ]
yeah yeah so that's the answer all right
man thank you take care
childish gambino that was a great shout
out that's another great call let's keep
it going
okay hi yeah Jerry I'm uh carry me I'm
Jersey I love that what part of church
I'm inviting Jersey great part of New
Jersey I'm so excited
here I've been falling into her a long
time so thank you thank you for having
me so um I'll get to it so I am the
executive group of brand-new boots we're
a full-service of social media and PR a
based in Red Bank and you know a little
back story I was PR director who are
many corporate fashion gremlins in the
city then I became an entrepreneur I had
a children's rock-and-roll teams play
space in Williamsburg Brooklyn then
we've got to New Jersey to raise my
family and started brand groupie so so
passionate about entrepreneurs small
business owners and I did everything I
could for four years to help small
business owners mastermind groups
started a podcast because of you
strategy sessions websites but after
four years I was still alone you know
with freelancers and so this year I made
the decision to scale and focus
primarily on b2b service brands and ATC
industry so community $30,000,000
companies and just focus on PR and
social so I hired a VP of public
relations amazing however I am doing all
the social myself and um my question to
you is in 2020 where should I focus my
time I want to be like ten steps ahead
of my climbing linked it LinkedIn okay
and I mean like excessively mm-hmm I
mean if you're going after 2030 million
dollar a year b2b players you know
what's gonna happen you've been around
the block for four years they're gonna
look for business results
mm-hmm and you know as fun as like
making five tik-tok videos is gonna be
that's not gonna lead to a lot of
business for that business in comparison
to a monster understanding best-in-class
of LinkedIn yeah I know that's that's
the game like you have to be the best at
the ads you have to be the best at the
content you have to be the best at
understanding who the influencers on
LinkedIn are and how you can do business
with them you have to understand every
nuance every you know comment you know
comment culture like you know back to
the Thank You economy so we're like on
five my books kind of play out it's Jab
Jab Jab right hook and to think you
economy and crush it because you got to
convince all your clients either them or
somebody that works for them needs to be
the face and you got to do a podcast and
put out content but I would say 90% of
your energy based on who you're
targeting needs to be on LinkedIn 90 ok
and should I just continue to grind
myself or should I hire anyone right now
or I mean look if you could afford it if
you can afford it you can absolutely you
know go that route but if you're if
you're still in that early stage which I
think you are and plus I'd love for you
to really know it like really know it
like you know like the thing that
separates me from everybody else is I'm
an actual practitioner yeah against the
people I compete against the CEOs of big
agencies don't even [ __ ] have a tick
tock account or an Instagram account
don't even have a yeah you know like and
so you know they're not making content
they're not living that life and so you
know that's a that's the reality of it
okay thank you so much Gary you're
welcome
thank you you're welcome one of my dad's
uh my dad's got some landscaping going
on here so that's like what is that
noise it's noise custom your life
happens around here social distancing
landscaping for pops alright let's keep
it going Gary what's up man what's good
Dave good man I'm uh doing well so first
I just got to say thank you man like I
know you hear that a lot but like for
real for real like a lot of stuff that
you've put out books the content deck
like completely change my business and
helped me help a lot of people which all
kind of make clearing my question so
root for real thank you but yeah man
it's crazy were talking about the
humanity footprint yesterday like that's
that's what my question is kind of about
and that's pretty much why I started my
business so can I give you like a little
bit of context cuz it's kind of a big
situation so
my whole life has been in the sport of
gymnastics right I've competed I was I'm
a coach I went to physical therapy
school and I was pretty much spent all
of my time working as a medical provider
and also as a coach right so 2013 I
started an online educational business
because the sport just desperately needs
like help for new ideas and working the
medical field it's like important that
people know what the new sciences and
stuff so I really just did it because I
wanted to help people because like a lot
of kids in the sport get her overuse
injuries like there's a lot of concerns
about like pushing young kids for like
their Olympic dream and college
scholarships and stuff so yeah it just
started like kind of as a fun thing and
blew up because of again like the
content model help me get more material
I'm not a businessman I'm not a marketer
I'm a I'm a practitioner in physical
therapy that's what I'm good at so I'm
talking about soft tissue yeah man so
alright I had this at the end of my
things as a thank you but when I texted
my question and I'm like my [ __ ] is like
back pain shoulder pain like that's what
I'm good at so the offer is on the table
if you ever want to help with your back
like I'm more than happy to do it no
strings attached but soft tissue is one
of the most important things there's a
couple other things they're super
underrated right for real yeah I think
like a lot of people don't realize it's
one of those things that like creeps up
on you and like you don't realize it's a
problem and then it's a problem and you
don't even realize it's happening
exactly yeah so lot you actually go at
it you're like well why does that hurt
so much yeah for sure so there's stuff
between like you know soft tissues
really important like what else do you
love so changing up your movement is
super important like if you sitting is
not bad for you it's just reversing like
what you're doing like so like laying on
your stomach is really important for a
while like you sit all day like I used
to blow up my back so I would rely and
so ring on your stomach for a couple
emails you're like doing some back bends
and stuff that's really and are you also
like a personal trainer yeah so I'm a
I'm a gymnastics coach a strength
conditioning coach and then I have a I
have my doctorate in physical therapy
and sports third fight therapist yeah so
like so you know one thing that's been
running through my mind I'm in love with
what's going on with my situation right
now I had my clock aunty for two years
that I joined him for three years Mike
again but I do think about like man I
should probably start to get to know a
person or two in case Mike like would
you ever live with me for a year or two
probably not live with because I got a
ton of stuff going on in my own but I
don't get it we just built the
telehealth infrastructure at our
really big no I need living yeah no I
keep conjuring all right going in
question couldn't live you but yeah so
long story short is um I've worked all
three jobs for seven years just like
going hard because it's just like a rare
opportunity to help a lot of people you
know and so I feel like the sport is
changing and I want to kind of
capitalize on that and so things were
going well for four years grew real
awesome but then in 2016 I don't know if
you know about this but we had like the
biggest scandal in history yeah right
the Michigan State [ __ ] yeah yeah during
all that stuff so you know the whole
world got tipped on its head and it was
awful and it was like it cut real deep
for me and a lot of my friends because I
coach a lot of young athletes and I'm a
medical mother I work exactly so I was
lucky that the work that I had done put
me in a position were like here in the
country International like a lot of
people like snap of a finger like ten
thousand eyeballs on me asking if I
could help and I had been putting up
tons of free content because I kind of
follow what you believe and we do
monetize that I have like some forces
it's not an online membership group but
it's always been like Barrett minimum
just to do the right thing for me okay
and so it happened and turned over and
like now it's like a huge a huge thing
is like everyone's changing there's a
lot of abuse like scandals that are
going on now they're resolving there's
so many good people that want to do the
right thing but don't have information
so that's where I feel like my humanity
footprint is to like make a dent in that
for the positive and so I've always had
this question but it's more now because
of like the severity of what's changing
is what like what's the balance between
I I want to give it all away for free
because I don't pull money from the
business I live off my physical therapy
career in my coaching career and like
just live or a boring versus like
holding on to the money selling the
content that I can use that to like hire
people or like you know you're both are
fine like you know I know that by
sometimes over demonize selling content
mmm but it's because so many people sell
bad content mm-hmm and even worse so
many people sell content that they rip
off from the internet somewhere else and
they just try to do funnels and do
marketing it your intent is clearly good
hmm like like I might decide to sell
content one day cuz I feel great about
it
it's don't sell something you don't
believe in yeah and also recognized
don't be mad at the world when they're
not buying your [ __ ] when they can go
google it totally make sense yeah I
guess to follow up it's more like on the
actual
tactics of like if I do hold on to money
which I'm fine with and I don't mind
charging for like consulting services or
like my physical therapy services we
charge for but like when I have money
like do I put it into like hiring people
like I hired I did it all for myself for
six years then I hired somebody last
year just to go bigger but it's more
like like into the finances of that
versus like if I give away the
information like and it's all out there
like it's clearly gonna start to like
chip away at my bottom line and stuff
and so I struggle personally no it's not
because it's gonna lead to leverage
which turn you into monetizing it in a
different way hmm yeah if the world
loves you for forgiving the way great
information it if if if if the world
loves you for giving away great
information
yeah and back to like soft tissue if you
decide to come out with your own rolling
ball with your beautiful bald head on it
you're gonna sell you know make more
money on that [ __ ] ball then you're
gonna make on the [ __ ] information
yeah and what are your thoughts on like
giving away content and then monetizing
just consulting services I thought about
that like that's what that yeah like
would that be a better option because I
could I've thought about dissolving my
like the medical courses you kind of
need to have those live or in person
because it's like a safety thing you
have to know what it treats them for out
course I like on my coaching education
group I could just give everything away
for free and be like alright if you want
to do you know like a university like
wants me to come in or like a country
like wants me to fly over and do it like
I could do that but then I struggle with
like it's important long-term its right
it's also against how you want to make
your money yeah there's no right answer
to this there's what's right for you
okay honestly which is liberating right
yeah you know but you also have to be
good at it you might be way way way
better at doing consulting and personal
than speaking and maybe creating a role
or product you know that stick that
bends the one stick look again like I
think there's a lot of opportunity you
know back to like like I'm not kidding
like if you're so great which I kind of
weirdly think you are I literally just
offered you like like the biggest thing
in my world around fist this intuition
yeah me I mean I think you could make a
hundred thousand dollars a year on a Mac
that people lay down and put their stand
lay on their stomach on yeah
it's kind of like me with wine like it's
people are gonna buy a mat anyway yeah
and if you're the guy to get like
like Dave you drink wine till don't lie
so I don't drink a lot of wine but I did
buy empathy and give it to my mom I love
you that's the answer right like if you
like for me all these [ __ ] faces that
are watching right now
the people that come here every day for
the last five years get free content in
perpetuity and yet still go to a BevMo
or a binney's or an h-e-b or a Costco
burn total wine or go to wine calm and
buy their wine that's devastating I want
to break their face cue the wine text
URL better but but so many more than
those people that somehow have not
clicked yet - like wait I'm buying wine
anyway
why wouldn't I buy it from the person
that's bringing me the most value yeah
yeah yeah so but but you have to have
the stomach like Dustin put it back up
hahaha but Dave you have to the stomach
for people to let you down yeah you know
like like I know as I'm reading all
these comments people that have
literally taken my stuff and made money
and obviously Texas Michigan under 21
outside the US you're all excluded but
there's people right now that are like
oh [ __ ] like genuinely just hit them
finally even though they watched for 60
days here like right why why would I buy
from wine calm why would I buy a total
wine like why in the world would I not
buy from Gary and the best part is I've
had Wine Library the whole time the
reason I'm pushing wine techs so hard is
because it's such a good deal yeah and
you can do the same thing you can you
can make such a good product that you
believe in and and and all that free
content you put out led to all of them
buying from you that way yeah yeah that
makes sense
and I guess the last thing that I'll let
you go is like the only thing that works
really well in our world is I don't know
if you have this on them on the media
side is like people can get the
information but they want to pay you to
see how you apply it they want to see
you treat people they want to see you
actually coke people so I feel like that
probably is like that would set the most
well with me is like here just for free
if you want to actually get my opinion
like that's cool love it you going
thanks man two things real quick a great
question what happened to Yummie text
Yummie text throw-up Yummie text in text
I know we don't go for it because with
koban and everything we're like on the
verge of fully launching Yummie text
yummy text is not R is in beta still and
with food and all this we just kind of
you know held off but as soon as we kind
of get back to some sort of normality so
yummy Texas for food Texas Michigan
here's your chance sign up for that but
real quick don't sign up for yummy text
or wine text unless you completely are
going to buy from it because it costs
money to send a text
so everybody who just signed up for wine
text just now cuz they felt guilty but
you're not gonna buy wine unsubscribe
it's super fine I only want people that
buy wine to sign up for it you know all
right but you should definitely sign up
for one text it's a [ __ ] crazy deal I
mean today we're selling a $70 wine for
30 a big time walking everyone some
perséphone worse in December 30 yes sir
we sold about $13 rose' you know like
it's just [ __ ] amazing anyway
nonetheless let's keep it going
yes Colorado is in Laurie hi hi how are
you good thank you so much for having me
here really it's great to have you Alex
for me our ladies are mighty so nice to
meet you no leaving it to ya I really
like your trash talk show just sayin I
really appreciate have you gone garage
selling yet I love it once we get back
to some normalcy I love it yeah
what can I answer for you bro yeah I'm
gonna like give a little context about
my question is stuff go ahead and like
it's about tick-tock I have two
questions I started to talk like a year
ago like I didn't really like I wasn't
really that like passionate about it
like long ago and and that long ago and
my siblings like started it so I just
got it for fun and things like that
yep and I I have HD and it's like it it
comes with like a hard time controlling
my emotions and things like that busting
with my
but yeah especially with my like
medication and it's like a side effect
and things like that but like tik-tok
like usually I just grow through it when
I'm having like a bad day and like it
like helps me and it changes my whole
mood that makes me so happy bro and like
when I could notice that a few months
ago I noticed that I can do that so like
people too and it like made me happy so
I just kept making videos every day and
like one comment that I got in my videos
I'm like it made the night and I was
like so happy I love that I love you
yeah I realized that I can like other
people but like it's such a special gift
that's super precious yeah I'm proud of
ya and then like that I'm not like the
hard time control my emotions and stones
like when I'm sad I'm sad but like it's
hard to like get hate comments cuz I got
like like I hate my old friends that
like you see me my friends understood
yeah but um ouch can I tell you
something about that yeah when people
leave hate on the internet it means that
they're hurting your quote/unquote old
friends it just means that they're
hurting inside too and the manifestation
of their own internal pain is being left
in your comments that's actually yeah
you see where I'm going
mm-hmm instead of feeling bad for
yourself when somebody leaves hate you
need to feel bad for them like
compassion like empathy like like
instead of being like hurt by them and
being mad at them you say why did Javier
or why did Rick do that and you say him
he's in a bad spot anybody who put
anybody who puts bad into the world is
actually hurting really bad inside bro
that's true cuz why else would they do
it then that's right they're trying to
bring somebody else down because they're
down meanwhile you got nothing but
sweetness and love in your heart which
is why you're trying to bring people up
yeah can I ask you this huge important
question
why is your mom's tea mug so huge she's
in the mug lights
let's go mug life that's what I would
say let's go my guide that's good [ __ ]
Alex you watch I love that but yeah I
have one more question
good so like I have like friends right
that Blake I'll take talked to like at
least three of them have like I like
they like doing basically the same
content that I put out okay cause they
get like a different response you know
like more more comments more followers
less worse yeah yeah yeah 100 yeah Alex
I promise you something right now
you want to get Rick you wanna you want
to limit the amount of time you're sad
let me promise you something right now
giving a [ __ ] about anybody else's
account
it's nice move in the world all right
bro they're happy be happy for them
you're a kind kid oh yeah yeah I'm happy
for them but no no no comma no comma
like I'm happy for them comma damn I'm
sad for me I want to be there yeah it
needs to be I'm happy for them
exhalation point okay yeah you got me
bro listen to me I'm gonna tell you
something that I hope you watch over and
over there is nothing I'm more confident
about then you're gonna win in life bro
I see it all right Jean yeah you got
nothing but good thank you so much
you just have to be patient and believe
don't worry about comparing and by the
way you know I don't want to pry into
this gets into more family stuff with
you and what you're talking about but I
promise you your your thing is your gift
not your [ __ ] weakness thanks that
energy leads to creativity bro I'm sure
I have it I just didn't grow up in the
system when they used to test this yeah
you understand mm-hmm you have a gift
bro if you do anything from this video
you take in your mind and you shift this
we all get sad we all get happy but I
promise you if you don't compare and if
you feel bad for people that are like
putting bad on you if you feel
compassionate and empathetic for them
like bro you're gonna win bro
appreciate that you got the ingredients
now you just gotta cook it yeah you
understand no I expect I expect you to
tag me on your first trash talk
tick tock video once this world deal but
okay yes dear cousin I'll say something
please so I I'm so happy that I was able
to find you and I introduce Alex to you
like sending him like clips and stuff
about you finally cut into it and you
know sometimes kids and moms they don't
want to listen to other mom really says
because I've been telling him the same
thing that you say cuz I'm learning from
you of course sometimes it takes
somebody else to come in and get them
you know clicking I really I'm very
happy that that I found you so I can you
know help him through you I couldn't
like if I told you how emotional that
just made me and my soul I thank you so
much for saying that you don't even know
what that means to me
thank you Alex I mean we're gonna be
friends you need to stay the course I
can't wait to be friends with you once
you'd have to go to school all the time
like you know alright please do me a
favor don't just make this a one moment
thing take when I sent you and put it
into your soul when people are leaving
behind comments or people are talking
[ __ ] in real life they're in a bad place
you need to be compassionate when other
people are winning you need to be happy
for them neither one neither your
friends that are winning or your old
friends that are tearing you down
neither one of those people have
anything to do with your life you got a
great mom she's got a great family
you got a great great head of hair your
cutest [ __ ] your [ __ ] you gotta
figure it out bro we got this you have
to get me in the show too I have some
stuff that I want to talk about
alright talked to Dustin he'll get you
in mom okay love you back take care of
you who love this [ __ ]
you know this like people spending all
their time like focusing on what's bad
in the world and then you have that
seven minutes all right let's get it
going
Nick Gary what's up man it's always
tough it's almost a kid I know it is
it's hard not to compare yourself in the
ears I don't even stuff to is so much
it's hard it's hard to not compare
yourself at 53
I'm pair myself for 30 you know so you
know I get it it's just so hard when
you're surrounded by that but I just
want to say an absolute legend honestly
I the way of your words as you can tell
even with them it just means so much to
a lot of people and you helped so much
with us going through this pandemic you
know outside of this everything like
I've been pulling you for a long time
this is honestly an honor so thank you I
appreciate it looking for small
background I'm living in Portland Oregon
I'm originally from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania I'm currently doing PPC
marketing at the moment right after high
school I ended up going to college
actually for computer science and then
graphic design and then I changed my
major again ended up dropping out after
a couple years because honestly I just
went because my mom wanted me to and I
wanted to make her proud so I went to
college and [ __ ] played video games
and [ __ ] gambled and went to the
track and [ __ ] garage showings and
Toys R Us Peter I paid off every kid in
Toys R Us and like every I went to ten
different Toys R Us in the Boston you
know you know Newton Needham like area
and literally paid off all the employees
to keep all the starting lineups in Star
Wars and Power Ranger and Spice Girl
figures in the back and then I would do
like literally all day when I was
supposed to be in class would drive
around you know and pick up all the toys
that they kept in the back for me that I
would then sell on early eBay for like
80 bucks figure when I would buy them
for $7.99
that was crazy yeah I did photography
actually as a part-time thing to kind of
get myself through and one but to be
honest with you I didn't know what I
wanted to do it was
design science I'm like that you were
creative kids to try to figure it out I
get it so I went into retail management
right after that because I did retail
before that so I went to the more kind
of management side of it and then went
into IT that's why I thought I wanted to
do turns out I don't like looking at a
computer screen 24/7 and my eyeballs
drying out and just coding and doing all
that stuff so I kind of put two things
together where I love people I love
interacting I love helping and I love
analytics and stuff so I was like
marketing that's what I want to do yeah
man if you love math and art and people
you're [ __ ] you got them you got the
juice exactly so with that said I was
able to kind of get an entry-level PPC
marketing job and everything that didn't
require a degree and I wanted my foot in
that I want to make sure you know not
only this is for sure what I want to do
but really get an idea of this is my
career path going I apologise Nick hey
Dustin yeah can you cue up the full Joe
Rogan clip where I even predict how much
money it's gonna go for I couldn't like
like a poet read Twitter I think and
then like play it in here that's at the
end can we like cue it up yeah I'll see
oh I'll start working on it I apologize
just had a thought no you're good that's
crazy by the way it's got to be an
enormous amount of money he's gonna take
to go over there it's being imported
that's a hundred million and there's an
interview I gave last year where I
literally threw out that exact number no
way yeah that's nice clip anyway keep
going
so anyways doing PPC marketing I've been
doing it for three years I love my
company honestly the culture of the CEOs
are great and stuff but what I've
realized doing just the PPC end of
everything is I wanted to do more and I
want to help these small businesses cuz
I do businesses anywhere from you know a
staff of one where it's just the owner
to 50 so it's rather just the ground up
or people that really are just kind of
starting and stuff and what I've
realized is that even though I'm their
PPC marketing person they need a lot
more they need a lot more ideas on brand
identity messaging how
where do I go from here what do I do for
my organic hunt and stuff like that I've
taught myself a lot of things outside of
just kind of the Google outside of
things to your Mabel to your
multi-dimensional and you don't want to
be dead and hold and either you have to
do it by yourself or you have to expand
with the New York right exactly and the
problem is is that we have departments
for every type of medium and stuff right
so so so Renaissance man the Swiss Army
knife doesn't fit the mold of the
infrastructure yeah and I want to grow
at this point and I am moving up you
know I'm doing an interim lead saying
right now and stuff and I really
appreciate my job and everything but it
doesn't spark the fire in me like that I
have to really go above and beyond for
businesses and be able to do a lot more
so I haven't actually a couple scenarios
I want to run by you one I actually have
a pretty good relationship with the CEO
and he sees a lot in me that he sees in
himself and stuff and what I want to do
essentially is kind of pitch him because
he's creating jobs within our
organization yes okay it's gonna work
like on the record it's gonna work on
the record it's gonna work based on the
culture based on like I want to meet
this CEO like he sat down he said uh
yeah he sounds [ __ ] awesome great
culture making up jobs he sounds like
[ __ ] like it has a lot of like the
same points of view I have I like him I
think you would get along with him I'll
send the information of dust and I want
to pry it right now but um I'll send
over yeah I think first go have that
pitch because maybe he turns into a
dragon and I don't want to be he's a
good guy
clearly the second option is I I think
this is the goal of a lot of people that
work for an agency is I want to do all
marketing for one company or be like a
marketing director for one company or a
brand or a certain industry even like I
do industries anywhere from like retail
to service to CNC machines and stuff
like that and some of it I have like a
true passion for assumptions Lou it's
just like yeah absolutely Nick sent me
an email
a real one okay yeah
that's one dude
you actually I'm taking everything back
if you have to write down Gary at
vaynermedia calm okay I'm actually
writing down you know just kind of
snippets and stuff for myself I know
yeah plus everybody learns differently
like I can't write down every anything
and then I'm actually fascinated by the
process of writing things down I think
it's kind of cool
I repeat it in my head without even
moving my lips and that's how I remember
things yeah but if I wrote it balmy dead
I'm gonna watch this 20 times over
honestly but for some reason it's a big
words ready don't do it Nick you don't
even need to watch this 20 times over
let me recap it for you yes like
literally right on your pad right now
capital y capital e capital s brother if
you know that is maybe what I'm gonna
end up putting on my gravestone like
what I'm teaching and what I'm trying to
convey is 98% of people watching this
right now live and no and I live in yes
yeah you're so uncomfortably obviously
talented I mean it like thank you I
think I want you to work for vaynermedia
or or there's 30 different jobs I can
put you in if you want to go brand side
but like yeah like you just need to
believe in yes answers yes to everything
all right and then when I guess talk to
the boss and create a job yes start my
own thing yes co-brand side literally
and I'm not kidding you're gonna love
this slip a [ __ ] coin or throw a dart
because you'll never know the
alternative all three are good let me
give an example yeah let's just play
this out cuz it's gonna help so many
people you're in a crossroads right now
and it's not even one-dimensional
crossroads it's like a three-legged
stool
do i dribble down on where I'm at things
are good go talk to boss and create this
cool role and [ __ ] build do I take
Gary up on it and kogo to Boehner do I
do I have Gary help me become the
digital brand director at Bojangles cuz
he sits on the board and I moved to
North Carolina let's play that I mean
let's say when you get to heaven this is
my dream of heaven that I can show you
every scenario of how things would have
played out and what you ended up doing
was you came and worked with me and and
that work you worked on Team Gary for
three years it built up your profile you
then you felt you met the are you
married now I'm guessing oh good you
found the love of your life you had a
great family or in the Jersey suburb
then you take that platform let's go
even crazier like I did with me and
trout I bring you into a brand you know
six years later now you own 5% of a
coffee brand CMO we're doing it and now
we sell it to Nestle for 200 million
dollars and you're only 46 years old but
when you fly to Nestle to close the deal
as we're doing the celebratory dinner
you chose on a chicken bone and you die
right like I mean that's literally how I
think about life you couldn't write to
Bojangles all the [ __ ] I said for the
first 90% of that story wasn't as good
you think great you made 150 thousand a
year you loved Charlotte it was good if
you also find another love of your life
you know like and you live this great
life and you live to 92 and have great
for great you know grandchildren and
this and that and the other thing you
just don't know yeah and I just don't
want to live my life with any type or a
gret like I at the same time I'm not
wasting my time to because I'm learning
so much because I do connect with these
organizations within our overall
umbrella learn a lot more about SEO as I
know you're winning you just need to
make decisions and jump in and not look
back and just do that forever I I think
my biggest hurdle you know just kind of
looking at things and I've a build with
it I haven't really explored a lot is a
lot of those you know bigger marketing
roles and stuff says degree required and
like experience then just you know
you're too good like like just reach out
and say I don't have it many are gonna
say yes and degree required is going to
go away
[ __ ] them yeah um one little thing too
is not required a Boehner you know as we
continue to dominate more firms are
gonna do that those are gonna copy
mm-hmm house rocker doing with eSports
and everything III asked that because
that's another industry that I'm
interested in just in general and I
haven't heard yeah well yeah I mean call
duty leagues going really well you know
obviously been quite enjoying being a
minority owner of a eSports team in a
sort of rocker make sure you follow them
on all socials ro kicked me out okay K R
uh it's going really well like you know
it's it's a it's a first year we were
doing in-person events so that we have
to do some adjustments but but the
reality is I'm learning a lot it's a
great space I'm really into eSports
that's good to hear Gary thank you for
everything I mean uh it's yes in my head
but sometimes it's just like the mom
were here from the game you you you like
many people thirty in a bubs put a
degree on a pedestal grew up in an era
where it meant something and you have an
insecurity around not having it and I'm
trying to pull that [ __ ] off your chest
me when I tell you means zero it means
zero yeah if I get my foot in the door
and least in an interview I can prove
myself I just want to get that
opportunity you know and instead of it
being auto rejected because I don't
click mark the box that's does I have
but agree you know if I get the
opportunity I've always been able to
proceed but bro then just reach out coal
to the CEO and tell them why you're
you're not going out that would dude yes
number yes okay I gotta follow on
Instagram yeah thank you Gary for
everything you got a brother
let's keep going Gary Vee thank you so
much man do it I'm so excited man oh
[ __ ]
so I'll just I'll just get right into it
I'm pretty sure we're probably gonna
come back to patients I feel that
patients has been you know I mean the
slogan of the show at this point even on
the coattails of Nick you know like I'm
four years out of grad school but it's
my question kind of revolves out until
like pushing like pushing through grief
my my first semester of grad school I
lost my mom and that was kind of like a
huge thing like I used it very much as
my driver like I use it to create that
body of work that was my master's thesis
I write about her a lot
I pretty much have like a pretty fleshed
out transcript of poems that are like
super grief heavy but they're totally
about her friends of mine where my
birthday is always super close to
Mother's Day so like last week was just
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] week just because it
it weighs up like dude it's it's it's
one of the most difficult events in a
human's life even when they're 80 let
alone when they're at this age so my mom
lost her mom at five and and I feared
and my dad lost his dad at 15 and so my
whole life I fear losing my parents and
it was such a big thing in our culture
and people died very early in a Soviet
Union and and I just have a lot of
empathy through you bro it's a real
thing thank you
you know like and I've lived through it
with with my dad and my godmother who's
my aunt
where you know I mean they lost their
mom when I was an undergrad so like I've
kind of like seeing like the different
stages of it you know but it's it's it's
completely different like that just
depending on like how you you know I
mean
you grew up like my mom was the one who
raised me my dad was working all the
time like he worked second second and
third shift so you know like and then
even when he was home he was still
working so like I completely empathize
with that but my mom was the one who
raised me and even though she was never
like my biggest cheerleader like I'm
first-generation Filipino American even
when like I would bring my mom to like
my art shows she would always be like
why do you do stuff this way
why is your work so dark like what like
she would always like question what I
was doing and I know like she would she
would support me like in perpetuity but
she was always just like you know name
in a sec
total chip and I I didn't have that my
grandma did that for me my mom my dad's
mom cuz she was around a lot but my mom
was like I would sneeze and my mom would
be like that's one of the great sneezes
of all time so I had the reverse of that
a little bit and shout-out to my friend
Becky it's it's her birthday today but
one thing that she was kind of like
talking to me about on my birthday was
like you know like you'll proceed
through this grief forever and there's
you know I mean there are still gonna be
days that like hit you like a Mack truck
like out of the blue there's nothing
anybody can really like say to you it's
it's it's still just your pursuit of
this thing that is with you forever
and there are just like some times that
you know any me I try to like not think
about like if she's you know I mean if
hypothetically she is proud of me or bro
this is one of the most difficult things
and II to get through you know like but
there is no time machines absolutely and
that's like kind of like the other thing
like I feel that sometimes like even
though like I'm pushing like with my art
and you know I think it was earlier this
week where you were talking about like
dude sometimes that Debu is gonna kill
you and like I sold like one big piece
like from my
my Master's show and that was like the
pretty much like my biggest W as far as
like that part of my life and how much
itself or its over four grand
whoo that's [ __ ] no but you know what
I mean it's it's constantly been trying
to you know I mean still stay within
like that then now there's this
established market value and it's a huge
play it's a huge play and you know I
mean it's it's a play that can be made
when you know you're showing at Boston
where that show was or like if you're
showing in New York but you know I'm
from like I live in New Bedford
Massachusetts and do I love I love this
community so [ __ ] much like Kristen
being Kristen like it's so much fun to
like watch and chop it up with I was
chatting with Curtis last night about
just this and like Mike's dating show is
super good like dude this community that
you have created and that everybody is
so dialed into is just huge so like
thank you so much for this is there
anything about with like what like like
where like is it are you just trying to
navigate the grief that's that's
essentially where like I'm sorry if I
was a little over all over the map you
didn't go over map you you look you went
to your truth I love your truth I'm all
over the map 24/7 listen to me the
reality of this is this you had a mom
that brought you so much value and you
had her for 20-something years right
yeah and that you know 70 I would argue
50 to 70% of people don't have mothers
that bring them value they brought them
negative value then with the remaining
twenty thirty to forty percent of people
that did have great moms that brought
them value another 25 percent of those
people lost their mom earlier than you
did
absolutely where like did you know like
Daniel brought that up that he lost his
mom super early lost his grandmother
super early and I was really hoping that
he was like gonna dive into it and then
I was like oh
yo bro what's that what's that hat
it's a rocker hat man this is what we do
appreciate you so much bro listen to me
the reality is is when I hear you talk
you're coming from such a light it's
funny when you said your art is so dark
because you're dealing with this
darkness with light even where it's the
way you're communicating this heavy
heavy hearted situation is actually with
enormous gratitude I can feel it under
your words thank you where where it's
funny because like I was kind of just
like front-loading my Instagram just in
case like you know hypothetically if
Dustin was gonna bring it up on on the
ship no like I just loaded like a whole
boatload of paintings up there you know
just it's good man I'm like I want to
take a look at it before before I let
you go here bro listen to me it's gonna
be there forever and it's gonna be
better every single day thank you
that is the historic truth you know what
I mean and you know maybe like I'm on
ticket oh come on
five thank you sir I'm your 5/18 dude
this is huge this is so huge you know I
mean you know this is about to go to
1,500 right oh man like for for what
everybody that's been on this show like
that has really have taken this moment
that like it's it's immense for what it
can do for us and like what it can do
for your whoa bro your stuff is really
interesting
thank you so much hey what's up with the
Magic the Gathering cards you got some
dude I'm like flip like baby like it's
is what we're is what we're doing I just
I just bought a box that like I'm gonna
do an unboxing video on Twitch and you
know what I mean likes start flipping
cards and like that's that's been a huge
part of my life like I've been in your
your your food contents pretty good too
thank you so much like we're like side
note attrition I see you working out but
you got a little gut like me oh yeah do
you my like it's dude pandemic life has
been like pandemic 15 is hard
15 makes Freshman Fifteen seem amateur
I'm with you yeah dude especially like
especially like being in your 30s you
know what I mean it's all like you you
don't you're not you don't know where
don't say more yeah you're not a
teenager no more that [ __ ] hits oh man
but uh do you like like my mom like the
biggest thing that my mom gave to me was
was learning how to cook and loving food
so like I know that art was my passion
and so like I leaned into it I have a
master's in painting and you know like a
boatload of debt that goes along with
that like I thought that I was gonna be
you know what I mean teaching college or
whatever but it just that just didn't
end up being the route for me and that's
fine so you know I mean how much debt do
you have are you willing to fall are you
willing to share over a hundred K like
it is I was gonna try I was gonna try to
get the vaynernation right now to go and
DM you to buy all your art and take you
directly out of debt that's a [ __ ]
piece no dude it's it's dude it's even
getting on this show dude it's a war of
attrition dude [ __ ] patience I'm
totally I'm totally with it like this
dude little man like warmed my heart I
was smiling so hard cuz you know even
especially like with his mom with the
with like and that they're gonna go
garage saling I'm like I know immensely
like appreciative of them listen to me
I really think off the springboard of
this moment because your copier your art
is real real good thank you there's a
real shot you can get out of debt in the
next year even with an economic slowdown
I just think all your [ __ ] is minimum
four thousand dollars now minimum and I
think I think you can stunningly sell 25
to my community alone and be out I'm not
kidding I think you're about to get the
weirdest DMS of your life I'm with it
you know what I mean like I'm willing to
you know I mean try everything
everywhere oh wait you're with it if the
basis picks you up and is offering you
5,000 a piece and 20 of them sell new
[ __ ] you're with dude oh I'm with it I'm
with it if nobody asked me for anything
right now you know that's like sup man
that I know that's exactly where I was
gonna say listen bro you [ __ ] won you
know you won you know you got all the
[ __ ] pizzas you had a [ __ ] [ __ ]
thing happen we all have [ __ ] things
happen that will be absolute life to the
end when you have so much blessings you
have so much [ __ ] good start [ __ ]
building thank you
like welcome I love everything that your
your that your giving in perpetuity dude
I got the the empathy try pack because
like I wanted to support you I dropped I
dropped some money onto all in challenge
you me paper no more money for me until
we're out of that hundo I mean
absolutely no more no more [ __ ] hats
no more [ __ ] wine no more all in
challenge unless the raffle tickets kind
of cool if you won well you know what I
mean New York yours is done like that's
that's all I was because listen me
I appreciate it to no end but I need to
get out of that hundo first and then
we'll get back to you know wine text
another [ __ ] like that I really
appreciate you bro you've got a great
heart this is I appreciate you bro
I really really thank you so much listen
I really think this was especially
Dustin this had like a sweetness this
was like a sweet [ __ ] show yeah I
mean I don't understand how people
understand like this is like the [ __ ]
sweetest place on earth what don't you
understand about that that um I'm
fascinated but I'm trying to think about
all the people that miss read me upfront
Oh gotcha aren't taking advantages free
content and then I'm not understanding
like I'm like [ __ ] Who am I miss reading
what am i miss leading right watch this
Dustin in the comments hey everybody
watching how many of you the first one
two two two three even four times that
you saw me or heard people talking about
me thought I was a complete con artist
full of [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy charlatan
wait he's gonna sell me something at the
end how many people just say me me in
the comments watch this doesn't hey they
come look at that
honest I really I didn't think that when
I first discovered you I really didn't
like I don't know maybe I'm naive or
maybe or maybe your intuitions good
where maybe was the piece of content
right it all depends what piece of
content true he causes too much somebody
said right like got effects people look
at all these me it's a couple nominees
know some people are the worst watch
this now instead of me if the first
piece of content you were like oh my god
reply now and put my guy reply my guy if
right away you saw him is like this is
my guy let's see let's see that that's
how I was but for me I think it was just
because the first time I heard you you
said you were from Edison New Jersey and
I was like oh cool Jersey guy what what
piece of cotton you remember the first
piece of Gandhi's yeah it will hurt it
was when you're on Elvis Elvis Tran yeah
[ __ ] radio yeah I was driving to work
and I heard it you're telling me right
now sweet when that piece of content
like I don't know have you ever worked
with that piece of content or dohsa I
always go back to it when I first
started working for you I always like I
say you're at Boehner did you like so I
didn't go into that I understand you
heard me on Alistair and huh where I
talked about like don't hate your job
yeah and then you literally under having
a job with me yeah I didn't know that
yeah I mean I didn't like quit my job
next day or anything but like I think
then one of my friends Ari shared like
an old keynote on Facebook and then I
was like oh it's that guy again and then
and then it just [ __ ] matter and now
you're [ __ ] international superstars
[ __ ] T community is upset you're more
popular than I am yeah I love you bro
you got the actors at the Rogen piece uh
yeah and you so you can load it and load
in the Garry BTB thing yeah okay and we
did the big flying text thing today
premium wine here's a good one if you
want to buy a Father's Day gift I'm
selling a $70 wine for like 33 bucks
today 32 bucks buddy
bucks so Father's Day gift highly
recommend today's wine your pops would
go nuts the two bottles of this if he's
a wine drinker so thank you for all that
my guys I appreciate all the people that
said me who persevering and came over so
I really appreciate you guys I really
appreciate guys a lot um couple things
you're about to see you gonna put both
of them or you just gonna do one I could
do both cool actually let's just you
know Gary BTB just put up that right now
we don't need to play that thing I think
we played the rogue in peace cause I
think people gonna be blown away if you
haven't heard yesterday merciful if you
have twitter sign up for this right now
it's [ __ ] amazing and then number two
we're about to play you a clip I put on
my Instagram yesterday but not full clip
the team cut it a certain way but then
later came out that it's reported
through somebody close to the sources
that it's a hundred million dollars that
Brogan got to go exclusive to Spotify
watch this watch big shot at the ck s
Camilla she said you'll buy three right
now
first shout out mmm she's gonna back to
me burn I sold three Brunell already um
this is me uh if you follow me closely
I've been talking about the Rogan thing
over and over and over and over again
but here's one clip where I even took it
to the next level and threw out a number
I think it's gonna blow your mind
thanks everybody - see you tomorrow oh
yeah attention always eventually gets
monetized when Joe Rogan inevitably
announces that he got paid a hundred
million dollars to exclusively beyond
whatever pop platform he's gonna go on I
have an announcement the podcast is
moving to Spotify it will become
exclusive to Spotify
so I think when Rogen inevitably does
Howard Stern to point out I think you'll
start seeing people realize oh there is
something here and I think people are
very basic they they look for a report
or a very simple ad product to make them
feel good while under estimating when
tens of millions of people are paying
attention to something inevitably
there's an opportunity to
like I said in that clip the reason I
knew is this how the world works like
you build up traction in all platforms
and if you're at the tippy top like the
Rogen is you then have the leverage to
go exclusive somewhere and extract
enormous dollars it's a big deal I
guarantee you got a real real check
Congrats Joe you worked hard for that
for everybody else who's aspiring get
into all platforms get out there build
leverage and then reverse